welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with the
gentleman now our worldwide it's time to
break down one of January's biggest
movies throughout this video we'll be
talking about all of the ins and outs of
the plot everything that you need to
know about the film and our thoughts on
it as a whole there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to see the movie yet and don't
want to know what happens then I highly
suggest that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into our breakdown of the gentlemen
okay so the gentlemen is pretty much
shot and edited with guy ritchie's
signature style the movie jumps about
from location to location moving
backwards and forwards through time and
his fourth wall breaking moments that
add a touch of dark humor to the
proceedings primarily it's told through
the eyes of Blecher a slick talking
cockney who narrates most of the events
of the film fletcher played by an almost
unrecognizable Hugh Grant has been
keeping his eyes on the London
underworld most notably Micky Pearson
and he is planning to blackmail a
character and his partners Mickey is a
high-profile drug dealer that has built
a large marijuana Empire hidden
throughout states in England
Mickey's had a change of heart though
and has decided that enough is enough
and it's time to cash out of the
business whilst he still can
Mickey wishes to sell his thriving
business to a rival competitor named
Matthew Bergere for a sum of four
hundred million dollars and it looks
like the deal is going to go ahead
unfortunately one of his labs is robbed
one night and thus the security and
anonymity of them comes into question
forcing Mickey and his partner Raymond
to get to the bottom of it
the plot is pretty complex and I can
imagine that many people will get lost
in it because it doesn't really let up
at all in typical Richie style it jumps
about from situation to situation
presenting scenes as anecdotes rather
than fully fledged plot points but by
the end of the film they all come
together in a seminal way Richie has
always been a master at creating almost
puzzle-like productions that you only
really get a full understanding of by
the end of the film this is definitely
the case with the gentlemen and had to
admit that a quickly became swept up in
its storyline due to the fast pacing and
a blinking your mister lines that bill
towards the entire hole
from a purely bird's-eye point of view
and in order to streamline the plop of
this breakdown we learn that bird you
wish to get a better deal on the
business and thus began working with
another rival gangster named Raya
he hired a gang to rob Mickey and
lowered the price on the offer
however the gangs mentor the coach
played by Colin Farrell discovered this
and learning of Mickey's reputation he
decided to try and get them out of
trouble so went to Raymond directly in
order to smooth things out this allows
Micky to discover Burgess real plan and
get back the original price that they
agreed on through locking him in a
freezer and the Manning he transferred
the money and also hand over a pound of
flesh
that's pretty much the major arc of the
storyline and what the main premise of
the film is there were several elements
that throw spanis in the works though
namely dry eye who decides to try and
achieve power for himself
this also is subplot involving one of
the richest State homeowners that wishes
to get his daughter back and the
employees Mikiko to do this when getting
the girl one of Mickey's henchmen
accidentally kills a young russian boy
who was later revealed to be the son of
a high-profile gangster who wishes to
get revenge they send an assassin to
kill Mickey but luckily Raymond shoots
him first and it's during this time that
he also kills dry eyes who was
attempting to kidnap his wife how about
have a lost year but anyway
Fletcher gives Raymond a deadline of 72
hours in order to get 20 million for him
otherwise he will send all of the
information to a media tycoon who owns a
newspaper known as the daily print we
learned that not only has Raymond
tracked where Fletcher hid the blackmail
material but that he is also called upon
the favour that the coach owed he and
his gang went to the owner of the daily
print drugged him and filmed him having
sex with a pig in order to keep
everything silent when Fletcher returns
for the money they put him in a box and
are just about to kill him but he died
bulges that the Russians are also making
attempts on their lives and thus is
allowed to go free after two assassins
sent for Raymond are killed by the coach
the coach's gang also believed that he
was being held in some way by Mickey so
they went to kill him but in doing so
ended up shooting the Russian assassins
that had managed to capture him Fletcher
goes to sell the story anyway to Miramax
and
director there looks very similar to a
certain mr. Guy Ritchie this is probably
one of the most fourth wall breaking
elements of the movie and I loved seeing
the poster for the Man From UNCLE as
well as several of the Easter eggs in
the office Fletcher has adapted the
story into a foam script known as Bush
this is a little nod to the original
film's title and during the production
of the movie this is what it was known
as before it was changed to the
gentlemen it was also known as tough
guys which also gets paid lip-service to
in the film Fletcher is picked up
outside and taken away by Raymond which
allows Mickey to settle down with his
wife though like a lot of Ritchie films
that the movie does leave some things up
in the air most notably the script for
Bush this details all of the ins and
outs of Mickey's operation and if the
movie does get greenlit it could
potentially cause some problems for the
character we do know that the script is
that Miramax but Raymond has the means
to silence it should it ever come to it
now one of the big questions I've seen
floating around about the film's ending
is is Mickey actually out but we're
really two ways you can look at it
though
but I do think that he is the main
reason that people believe that he is in
is because earlier in the movie Mickey
and his wife have a sort of back and
forth about how he will struggle leaving
it all behind
Mickey propositions his wife by saying
any chance which she rebuffs because
there are hints that she doesn't want
him to leave the drug business and she's
displeased that he's considering it
however at the end he once again asks
and she closes the door suggesting that
the two get it on which ends the movie
now the fact that she is accepting of
this shows that he's probably still
involved with the underworld
there's also Raymond who is still
cleaning things up for Mickey most
namely Fletcher the deal with virtue
resources something I've seen people
bring up as handing over four hundred
million dollars and a pound of flesh
will likely sting the character but
there are hints that the deal did go
ahead by the use of a steak on a grill
after the demand is asked of the
character so it does look like he went
through with it and though many think
that he is still in the game personally
I think he's out and this closing of the
door at the end is a symbolic closing of
the door and is our lifestyle he does
say in the movie that he does want to
settle down with his better
which this scene of the two together
shutting the door on that past
definitely symbolizes Burchett has
handed over the cash and a deal is a
deal so he will now be in charge of his
empires and he will likely leave the
character alone because of fier
obviously though let me know your
thoughts below on the meaning behind the
final few minutes but personally I think
the character is out for good but what
did I think of the film overall well
though it doesn't quite recapture the
feeling that I had when watching lock
stock for the first time this is
definitely one of the directors bests
it's stylistic in all the right places
smooth charming funny and wickedly
edited it provides a real commentary on
life in England too with characters
coming from council estates all the way
up to the 1% Richie has always had a
flair for dialogue and this is massively
on show here with characters spouting
off some incredible one-liners in
brilliant fashion everything fits
together nicely too and though a lot of
elements initially seem unimportant
everything ties together neatly at the
end to make a hole Richie
expertly places building blocks and
these all come together to form a
brilliantly slick storyline that I had a
lot of fun whilst watching it's too
early to say if this is one of the best
movies of the air but looking at the
other entries in the month I think it's
definitely up there with 1917 other than
that there's not really anything out
there like it and it's a blast from
start to finish
Ritchie is back on his a-game and
hopefully this kick starts a decade for
him with a new direction after a couple
of his last movies felt quite short all
of the cast are great and having a blast
with the material especially Hugh Grant
who's never really played a part like
this before and for a guy who's very
typecast he completely transforms in
this role and is brilliant throughout
the movie overall I had a hell of a lot
of fun with a gentleman and that's why
he gets an 8 out of 10 and obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the
gentlemen and what you thought of the
film comment below and let me know and
if you enjoy this video then please give
it a thumbs up make sure you check out
our breakdown of 1917 which is gonna be
linked at the end we go over everything
you need to know about the movie so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more you'll become chat to
me after the video that makes you follow
me on twitter at definition whitey will
head over to my discord server which is
good
be linked in description below we drop
videos on there early so if you want to
see stuff before anyone else and that's
the best place to be it's pre adjoining
we have an awesome community so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
this is the channel for people who were
mad into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]